we're asked to convert 150 degrees and
negative 45 degrees to radians
so let's think about the relationship
between degrees and
radians and to do that let me just draw
a little circle here so that's the
center of the circle and then do my best
shot to
best attempt to freehand draw a
reasonable looking circle
yeah that's not
i've done worst i've done worse than
that all right
now if we were to go in degrees if we
were to go one time around the circle
like that
how many degrees is that
well we know that that would be
360 degrees
well if we did the same thing how many
radians is that if we were to go all the
way around the circle
well we just have to remember when we're
measuring in terms of radians we're
really talking about the arc that
subtends that angle so if you go all the
way around you're really talking about
the arc length of the entire circle or
essentially the circumference of the
circle and you're essentially saying how
many radius successes or radii or how
many radian
radius radii is the circumference of the
circle you know a circumference of a
circle is 2 pi
radius is 2 pi times the radius or you
could say that the length of the
circumference of the circle is 2
pi
radii 2 pi
radii if you want to know the exact
length you just have to get the length
of the radius and multiply it by 2 pi
that's just the def that just comes from
the really actually the definition of pi
but it comes from what we know as the
formula for the circumference of a
circle so if we were to go all the way
around this this is also 2 pi radians
this is also 2
pi
2 pi
radians
so that tells us that 2
pi
radians
as an angle measure is the exact same
thing and i'm going to write it out as
360 degrees and then we can take all of
this relationship and manipulate it in
different ways if we want to simplify a
little bit we can divide both sides of
this equation by 2
in which case you are left with if you
divide both sides by 2 you are left with
pi radians
pi
radians
is equal to
180 degrees
is equal to 180
degrees 180
degrees so how can we use this
relationship now to figure out what
150 degrees is
well this relationship we could write in
different ways we could divide both
sides by 180 degrees and we could get pi
radians
pi radians
over 180 degrees
is equal to 1 which is just another way
of saying that there are pi radians for
every 180 degrees or you could say pi
over 180 radians per degree the other
option you could divide both sides of
this by pi radians you could say
you would get
on the left hand side you get one
and you would also get on the right hand
side you would get 180 degrees for every
pi radians
180 degrees
for every pi radians for every pi
radians or you could interpret this as
180 over pi
degrees per radian
so how would we figure out how would we
do what they asked us so let's convert
150 degrees to radians let me write the
word out so
150 degrees
degrees well we want to convert this to
radians so we really care about how many
radians
there are how many radians there are per
degree actually let me do that in that
color
so we care about how many radians
radians
there are per degree
per let me do that same green color
per
per degree
well how many radians are there per
degree we already know there's pi
radians for every 180 degrees or they're
pi
pi let me do that yellow color there are
over 180
pi over 180 radians per degree
and so if we multiply this all works out
because you have degrees in the
numerator degrees in the denominator
these cancel out
and so you are left with 150 times pi
divided by 180
radians so what do we get
well this becomes just rewrite it
times pi
all of that over 180
all of that over 180 so this is equal to
and we get it in radians
radians
and so if we simplify it let's see we
can divide the numerator and the
denominator both by looks like 30. so if
you divide the numerator by 30
you get 5 you divide the denominator by
30 you get 6. so you get 5 pi over 6
radians or 5 6 pi
radians depending how you want to do it
now let's do the same thing for negative
45 degrees what do you get for negative
45 degrees if you were to convert that
to radians
well same exact process
you have
negative and i'll do this one a little
quicker for negative 45
degrees i'll write down the word times
times pi
radians
pi radians for every 180 degrees
for every 180
degrees the degrees cancel out
and you are left with negative 45 pi
over 180 radians
so this is equal to
negative 45
pi
over
180 over
radians
so how can we simplify this well it
looks like they're both at minimum
divisible by
9 times 5 is 45 this is 9 times 20. so
actually it's going to be divisible by
more than just let's see nine nine
they're both well i will just actually
they're both divisible by 45 what am i
doing okay so if you divide the
numerator by 45 you get one you divide
the denominator by 45 45 goes into 184
times four times you're left with
negative pi over four radians so this is
equal to negative pi over four
radians and we are done